this is a production of cornell
university
thank you so much jeff for this
invitation it's really wonderful to be
participating and i
wish that i had been able to do this in
person
but unfortunately
our world has been turned upside down by
the pandemic but
it's still lovely to be able to present
this virtually
so i'm going to kick start
this um by
an introduction to the cape floristic
region
and then i will move it along and
ultimately discuss some of the plans
that i actually work with in my
particular environment
so i'm just quickly grabbing my pointer
here
there we go and
i'm sure you might much be you must be
well aware
that the biodiversity in the world
actually is not necessarily equally
distributed
um you know throughout the whole entire
world
and there are several different
biodiversity centers
and some of them actually are regarded
as megabyte diverse centers
especially in terms of plant life in
south africa
we have our national flower the protease
androids or the king protea
which actually belongs to the one of the
most dominant
uh groups of plants in in the cape
the proteaceae together with the erica's
and even the rescuers and we also are
home
to three different biodiversity hot
spots
the cape floristic region that has about
9 000 species
in a very very small area and then
succulent peru which is a semi-arid area
that has about 10 000 succulent species
and is
pretty much well renowned for hosting
the largest biodiversity of succulents
in the world
and then the land ponderland albany
corridor
and i'm going to try not to say this too
many times because it is
a little bit of a tongue twister so i'll
just call it
the mpa this particular region has about
1
900 plant endemics and i'm going to now
focus on these three different hot spots
in south africa
so the maputo land uh pondolan albany
corridor actually runs
along the west the eastern part of south
africa
which is actually bordered by the indian
ocean and that
this particular environment is actually
regarded as being semi-tropical
and the plants that you'll find there
would be
forest species and trees such as
erythrana kafra there are also savannas
that are chock-a-block full of different
types of grasses
different meadows and some some
shrublands
and this is pretty much where i
originally actually did
my um studies before i moved down
to the southern parts of south africa
and to the southern tip
and in the southern parts of south
africa you've got two of these
biodiversity hot spot
the one actually being the succulent
karoo
which stretches all the way right up to
libya
and on this part of of south africa
you actually have the atlantic ocean
which is much
uh cooler in terms of its waters
and in the cape peninsula right at the
tip
of africa the indian ocean and
the atlantic ocean actually meet and
they create a very
interesting and unique set of climates
which in some ways are thought to be
involved in a speech
species richness that is actually found
right here
in the southern tip so some other
interesting plants that are actually
found in the succulent crew happened to
be huri agronia
which is utilized by people and is
exploited commercially as an
appetite suppressant but you also have
interesting aloes such as this uh aloe
tree
that would be found in these semi-arid
areas and the villagers
that are punctuating the
semi-arid areas that are sitting again
in the succulent peru so what about the
plants that are actually sitting in the
cfr or the cape floristic region
what do they actually look like
well these plants are very diverse in
their character
and most most of them are actually
highly endemic
um in nature interestingly
at the moment the dices are actually
flowering
so a lot of different hikers and
natural enthusiasts are actually making
their way
all the way up to table mountain to try
and
meet with these plants that are
currently in flower
so the biodiversity that actually exists
in the cape floristic region
is thought to have been
evolved as a result of many different
factors and some of the hypotheses
that have been uh proposed
uh are linked to the varied landscapes
that you actually
found find here and the different
ecological niches that are actually
part of the environment of the
characteristic region
peter linda in 2019 actually proposed
that the radiation of this
cape flora was not necessarily due to a
singular event
but might have been a mixture of
older radiations and more recent
radiations
so we don't currently know why this part
of the world is so
rich in a variety of different
species some have
thought that it may be the pollination
syndromes that
that are existing here and the
interactions might have actually driven
adaptive um evolutionary processes as
well as convergent evolutionary
processes might have actually been
acting that might
ultimately have resulted in the degree
of this botanical gold that we actually
have here on the southern tip
the environments can be very variable
so if you travel from cape town and you
head out towards the semi-arid areas
like we did last year you'll end up in a
place called the tanko crew
and really it is pretty much desert
but when the winter fall
comes winterfall um rains actually come
they ultimately lead to an explosion
of flowers in these succulents that are
actually found in these particular areas
and again this difference in climate
and this interaction of the environment
the phenology of the plants is also
thought
to have been a very important driver of
speciation in the area
there's also a very dominant
fire regime that has also
thought to have been involved in
actually driving speciation in this area
and the fame boss or the fine bush
which happens to be this shrubby
vegetation type that actually dominates
the cape
peninsula is very fire dependent
this afternoon this whole set of
mountains where i actually live
was actually covered in smoke and
the fire season is really on at the
moment
and these fires actually bring
not only um the heat but also the smoke
itself is very important for the
germination of those species
so these life strategies that
have been evolved by the plants around
this region
are also thought to be important for the
establishment of the species that are
actually
found here
interestingly enough we also have snow
in south africa in certain parts of
south africa
so in the mountains of the cape you will
often
see you know snow caps and sometimes the
fame boss actually gets covered in that
snow
and the drops in temperature the
moisture that's actually brought on by
the snow
is actually probably also quite
important in
triggering and flowering of the winter
dependent species in other parts of
south africa
in places such as hawksback
which is very close to where i was
actually born
you have quite a deep amount of snow
that will actually settle in those areas
and i put this um particularly because
um jeff and i have been sharing about
you know the differences in the climates
um here in the south versus in the north
at this particular time
and this picture is taken in hawksback
and some of the plants that i actually
found there because
that area belongs to the mpa happen
to be beautiful species of the iridesce
as well as the streptococcus
species are actually found in these
particular regions
so these variable geoplanatic conditions
are also thought to have driven
speciation in this part of the world
also the soils are
ancient especially in the cape floral
region and these ancient soils
are low in night in nitrates and they're
low in
phosphates and so plants around this
region
have really acquired very intricate
mechanisms in in order to be able to
maximize
on their mineral nutrition such as the
cluster roots
which are are produced
by the proteus that actually facilitate
the acquisition of nutrients
and as you can see this is actually a
picture that was taken
last year um and
we were all massed up while we went into
the field
but it was a really fun time because we
saw many proteins that were flowering
and at the same time we also got to meet
with these cluster roots
that are an important mineral nutrition
strategy
for protease and the plants
in this part of the world are really
quite
variable you will have
the succulents such as these estonians
for example that actually utilize
thorny strategies to defend themselves
against
herbivores you also have drosseros
that are reliant on animals in order to
provide them with nutrition
and different species that have become
horticulturally important such as the
bruneas
and some species that are of medicinal
value
such as this elephant's foot and
even different species that
are of ornamental interest
that serve as inspiration for landscape
artists
the plants are variable they are quite
beautiful and many of these species
serve as a very important
part of the bioeconomy of south africa
so the people of south africa are also
quite diverse there's a very rich social
and cultural biodiversity
which in itself actually matches the
plant biodiversity
so at this particular juncture i'd just
like to
bring a little bit of history in terms
of how this
sociocultural biodiversity came about
in in fact the original
[Music]
of the southern tip of africa happened
at some stage they were actually joined
by
who came through central parks and
ultimately
towards um the southern tip
and then in the 16 1700s
the dutch settlers started to actually
settle
around this area and the brits came
around the 1800s
bringing together with them a slave
trade
that brought to to this part of the
world
people from the east and this has
created a
very unique and a very diverse
ethno-pharmacopoeia and so
people exploit this biodiversity
for many different reasons and they
connect this exploitation to their
histories
so different people are actually found
in south africa are indicated
and this then leads to a different
set of indigenous knowledge systems
if you are in the
mpa area you will meet zulu people
and sangwamas that's a zulu word for
a traditional healer but then if you
travel
towards the cape you'll actually meet up
with
america which happens to be of course
our origin
but right in the southern tip the bush
doctors or bossy doctors in afrikaans
are the main commodifiers of herbal
medicines
that are actually herbal plants
that are actually found in in this part
of the world
and all of these different cultures have
got different
indigenous knowledge systems which they
claim connects them to their ancestors
and they actually bring this history
into a contemporary context
most of this material is actually
harvested in the wild
and this of course does cause an
extinction
threat and species such as this uh
wild african ginger or saphenokinis
europeans is actually
um in extinct in the wild
but that type of wild harvesting of
medicinal plants in south africa is
not the driver of plant extinctions
it is mainly expanding urban
developments
expanding agricultural development
invasive species and all of these
anthropogenic activities
are actually driving plant extinctions
in this particular
part of the world even so
the exploitation of plants by people
is a very deep culture it is an oral
practice
that is actually linked to the informal
trade of medicinal plants many of these
plants are actually
collected in the wild and then brought
into urban centers and traded as part of
a livelihood
generation for about 60 to 70 percent of
the population
at the same time there is a formalized
trade of medicinal plants
that has led to a variety of different
phytopharmaceutics that are not
necessarily only sold in south africa
but are actually sold globally
such as an extract that
is made from penegonium pseudoides
that is manufactured for um as a
respiratory
um uh treatment
and it is called umaka cold care in the
united states
and it goes by you know different trade
names in different parts of the world
and of course weibus or aspalathes
lindiaris
is cultivated but at the same time
there is some wild harvesting that
actually still takes place
in order to service this
phytopharmaceutics
industry that is a growing
industry in south africa
so in our particular environment we are
interested in the plants that
are exploited by people that have not
necessarily been well studied but at the
same time we are also interested
in plants that are actually
commercialized or have a commercial
potential
and we utilize a diverse
range of scientific tools
that are linked to biotechnological
strategies some of these involve
second generation biotechnology such as
plant tissue culture
but we also utilize third generation
about technology
where we actually alter the genetics of
these plants
and we use a metabolomic set of
pipelines
that actually facilitate us to be able
to understand
what is actually happening to the
chemistry whether we are looking at
plants that may be collected in the
field
or plants that are in cultivation as
all of that hopefully allows us to be
able to
tell us a bit deeper about what might be
happening at the physiological
biochemical and even genetical level
within the actual cell so at this
particular stage i actually want to move
the discussion to discussing
some of the plans that we actually focus
on in my particular
laboratory so the first species that i'd
like to talk about
is one that is becoming a firm favorite
for me
and this is skeletium tautosum from the
um family museum brent miyaci
it grows in the succulent karoo
and it is one of eight different species
within the skeletal genus
it is the only species at this
particular stage
that has been commercialized and it has
been commercialized for a set of
mesomarine
alkaloids that are known to have
a central nervous system acting
in animal tissues
so we are a little bit worried about
this particular species because it's
becoming quite
popular as a commercialized product
but even in popular culture uh
people are starting to exploit
this particular plant because it does
give you a sense of
euphoria if you chew on this
leaf material or you take it as an
extract
so there are some conservation concerns
um with with regards to this with
people actually collecting plants um in
the wild
but at the same time we also want to
service the commercial
industry around skeletium with some of
the work that we've actually been doing
so just to give a background
already in in the 1600s
simon finder style actually foresaw the
potential of this particular species
when he went on a set of explorations
in the cape touristic region and even in
the succulent peru and he met up with
the quaker and the sand people
and he found them actually consuming
this particular plant
for religion and spiritual purposes
and it is only in the 1970s
that the mesomarines were actually first
isolated
from these particular plants and this
research
took on a positive trajectory from the
1990s
and it is only really now that we are
starting to understand
what these limits and green alkaloids
and particularly mesenbrine
is actually acting in animal models we
do know
that it is able to bind to brain
receptors
and it has an anti
anxiety effect it does increase
concentration
and it is actually being
also commercialized as an antidepressant
and it is included included in a variety
of different products at this particular
stage
so we did a study which looked at a
single
isolated population that actually occurs
in
the cape nature reserve that is actually
called kamhabar
nature reserve this is between two small
towns that are known as calixtor
and oatsworm and these are positioned in
the succulent peru
and we focused on this particular
population
because it was actually occurring as a
single isolated population
with the plants actually clustered on a
on a a single slope and when we go
out into the field we noticed several
different things
one of the things that we noticed is
that these plants are
always hidden we don't know if they hide
themselves
to prevent animals from actually seeing
these plants
and preventing herbivory or
is it for a uv protection purpose
purpose or is it because they are
actually
able to get a little bit of shading from
the highlight intensities that are
prevalent in these areas
or is it perhaps due to the fact that
they actually acquire
water that actually pools amongst these
other
plants that they actually hide
underneath
so we collected plants in the wild and
then we monitored them over different
seasons and then we also established a
cultivation strategy that i'm going to
talk about
as i proceed with this particular
research that we conducted in skeletal
so the first interest was to actually
look at
different seasonal effects we looked at
plants that are collected during the
autumn solstice the winter equinox
the spring solstice and even the summer
solstice and we measured a whole bunch
of
growth production parameters and what
is actually interesting is that even the
different um
positions of the birds actually has
an impact on the metabolites and
depending where these buds are actually
positioned
you have increased production of
bitter lanes during different
seasons what about
the mason breeze the meso marines
really alter quite significantly
mesomarine
itself as an alkaloid starch to starts
to accumulate at higher levels
in plants that are actually
growing in spring
but in summer many of these mesomarine
alkaloids that we actually monitor
start to increase in their production
and their accumulation seems to be
um developmentally regulated as well as
having a spatial and temporal
regulation and so we were interested
to better understand how
these mesobrain alkaloids are actually
distributed
in different parts of the plant at
different
times and so we set up
a tunnel experiment where we started
growing clones of mesomarine that we
are skeletium that we had um established
and then we monitored mesembrine
alkaloids and egg chromatomatic tissue
in different tissues that were different
developmental stages
so leaf one is actually one of the
youngest
leaves whereas
leaf six is starting to smash
and generating these skeletons that
actually shield
the inner leaves of the plant
and we also looked at stem chemistry
in terms of the mesomeres as well as
analyzed
the auxiliary buds to better understand
what was actually happening in that
particular tissue type
we were able then to establish
some patterns after using multivariate
statistics
and this looks quite complicated but i'm
going to try and keep it quite simple
so for example the stem tissues started
to increase production of
a wide range of mesenbrunol
isomers and interestingly enough
mesemarin itself started
to actually accumulate in another tissue
type
where the much younger leaves actually
seem to
start to express um
different amounts of different
isomers of mesobranol but then at the
same time
these also seem to appear to have much
higher levels
of mesomere and the stem tissues
themselves
also actually do accumulate at certain
stages much higher levels of measuring
i keep emphasizing on mesomarine itself
because the industry that produces the
phytopharmaceutics of skeleton actually
monitor
mesembry and about four
other alkaloids are also monitored but
they'll have a very deep interest
in mesomere itself
so i'm just going to play a an animation
here
and i want you to basically track this
um arrow that focuses on mesen green at
different
um stages of
leaf development going from the apical
meristem
meristematic tissue looking at the
development of
of the mesenbrine in terms of its
relative
abundance and it ends off
at the auxiliary meristematic tissues
so i'm just going to play this animation
and we start off with a chromosomatic
tissue
and different tissue types you can see
that measuring
biosynthesis is actually changing
in different types of the tissue we are
able to monitor
monitor a variety of different mesa
brains
and what's interesting is that the
pathway of
biosynthesis of mesobrain is still
pretty much unknown
because our information is based
on jeff's papers which were actually
published in the 1970s
we still have many different questions
that we don't understand
in terms of the relationship of
different
types of mesembry knowns for instance
with each other
and we also don't know for example
where this mesenternol might necessarily
be derived
is it coming directly from mesenbrine or
are there other different kinds of
precursors that are actually leading to
this particular mesenbrunol
and we still have many questions in
terms of
how this biosynthesis is actually
regulated genetically
and we still have many different
questions that are
actually in our in our minds with
regards to
whether these metabolites are actually
removed
from the apical meristematic tissues and
suddenly deposited in the older leaves
and even
even in the stems so there are many
different questions
which we still need to answer with
regards to the synthesis
and the and the spatial and temporal
regulation
of mesembry alkaloid biosynthesis
at the same time the extracts themselves
are not necessarily well characterized
because many different alkaloids are
still
not necessarily known to us so we think
that
better characterization of these
extracts
will facilitate us to be able to
um have a better understanding of the
biochemistry
of mesenbrine alkaloid metabolism
but at the same time will actually
facilitate
the commercial industry
to provide an extract
that is well understood in terms of its
chemical
character at the same time
there's much information that's actually
lacking
in terms of the contribution of the
minor constituents
which have not necessarily been resolved
in terms of their central nervous
nervous
system acting
processes so
in our labs we have been quite
um quite lucky
in actually establishing a tissue
culture system
which um is based on a callus production
but also um facilitates the production
of micro
micro shoots what's quite interesting
about
these callus cultures that we have in
our laboratory is that
they continue to produce a variety of
different mesomarine alkaloids
even though there is no formal
organization of the tissue
and this is quite unusual
because often these
very sophisticated metabolites actually
require some kind of organ formation in
order to be able to accumulate
we think that this type of system
might be an easier system to
industrialize
when we actually set up bioreactors
that may become an alternative source of
mesomer alkaloids
that kind of culture system might
actually alleviate
pressure on wild populations
but at the same time provide more
standardized and quality assured
extracts for the industry that is
exploiting skeletal biodiversity
so there are many questions that we
still don't know
and some of the questions that we are
interested in is actually getting a
better understanding of the chemical and
genetic diversity
in terms of skeletium as aginus
we are also interested in understanding
whether
the other species of skeletal have
any pharmacological activity whatsoever
and whether that chemical diversity
is actually matched to the but to the
binder by a
bioactivity and then to better
understand
the modes of action of these different
extracts that we might actually generate
from different species of skinny tip
so i want to bring on a second example
at this particular stage
and this example is linked to a
legume a south african legume known as
southerlandia fruit essence
that is found in the cape floristic
region but
actually also occurs in other different
biomes
such as the mpa biome and even in the
succulent
karoo this particular species
um has been a species that we've been
studying in my particular environment
for quite a few years now
utilizing both biotechnological
strategies
as well as again this eco metabolomics
approach that we use in our lab
so we've been interested in both
centralized metabolism and even
specialized metabolism in terms of this
particular
plant and i will today talk about a set
of
experiments that we actually did
that look at mineral and nutrition in
this particular species
before i do this i just want to give a
little bit of background with regards to
this particular plant
it's regarded as a multi-functional
herbal
remedy that has been commercialized
and continues to be exploited by
local people it has a long history in
terms of
its medicinal use and
it is actually called in afrikaans
or cancer bush and it is claimed to have
been utilized
by the aboriginal people actually as a
treatment for cancer today
it is regarded as a
anti-diabetic treatment
and it is also used to relieve
stress and at the same time
it has been commercialized for um
you know many different other reasons
which i'm not necessarily going to go
into today and agricultural
production is actually happening at a
small scale
and there is still a reliance on wild
collections
we first did a study
together with elene houston's from the
flanders institute of biotechnology at
the university of ghent
where we used a genetic strategy to
alter
secondary metabolism the work
that we did with elaine involved
a signaling peptide which was discovered
in his particular laboratory that's
known as taxamine
it is a signaling peptide which was
thought to alter secondary metabolism
and at the time we were doing this work
its function
in plants was largely uncharacterized
this project uh resulted
in us exploring the effect of the
signaling peptide
in arabidopsis
as well as inside the linear fortessens
in arabidopsis the over expression of
this peptide actually causes
a wide diversity of different
morphotypes that are
quite quite abnormal and
somehow the over-expression of this
particular
peptide is thought to actually function
at the morphological
level in terms of arabidopsis it doesn't
alter
secondary metabolism significantly
but there are minor alterations in terms
of
primary metabolism so we thought
then that perhaps the same effects
in southerlandia might actually occur
as a result of over expression of this
particular
taxamine signaling peptide so we
explored this in our
laboratories and uh using
a hairy root culture system that had
been set up in my lab
and ultimately we then did a variety of
different treatments
we treated with methyl jasminate to
induce
secondary metabolic events
we looked at non-transgenic
plants that had been generated from
these hairy roots
and also explored uh transgenic roots
that had been treated with methyl
gizmonic acid
what was quite interesting was that
a diversity again of different
morphological
traits that was associated with these
hairy roots were quite
obvious and at the same time
the main compounds that are found in
southern india so the
which actually happen to be cycloattene
glycosides these are terpenoids
and even uh interesting flavonoids that
accumulate in sutherland in
southerlandia
were differently produced
in the different uh transgenic cultures
that we had actually generated
with this taxamine over expression
as well as the methyl jasminic acid
treatments so it was then quite clear
that taxamine might have different
regulatory roles in different plant
species and so
that particular study then also led us
to exploring
what might actually be um
the type of chemical diversity
that might actually be out there in
nature
because we had actually at that
particular stage
utilized plants that had actually been
isolated
or extracted from populations in the
western cape
so we went out into different parts of
south africa
the plants are in red here actually
collected from areas of the succulent
peru
and these were actually compared to the
western cape populations
and the plants that are indicated in
yellow actually grow
in this area that's part of the npa
and it was quite clear that plants that
came from different regions
actually expressed a different chemical
character what was also very interesting
was that these plants had different
types of bioactivity
so plants that are actually found in the
crew
area have got anti-cancer by activity
whereas
plants that are actually growing in the
western cape particularly in coastal
areas
have got high levels of antioxidants and
so we
think that it would be better
for the industry to choose
specific chemotypes for a specific
and particular bioactivity
so we had this hypothesis
that the differences in
the chemical character might actually be
linked to the different environments
where these plants were actually found
and so we then explored um
a tissue culture based system where we
actually changed
the amount of phosphates and then we
also changed the amounts
of nitrates in a controlled
tissue culture environment what was
quite
obvious was that the different
treatments
that were associated with
low phosphate or even
nitrate nitrates actually resulted
in a difference in amino acid
signatures that i actually found in in
the treated plants
some of the compounds that were actually
expressed
at much higher levels or increased in
terms of their relative abundance
actually happened to be the
sugars and these types of sugars are
actually very important
in stress responses as a whole in plots
and also specific metabolites such as
spermine asparagine and gaba
are all important in facilitating plants
to be able to cope with stress
at the same time we conducted a
proteomic analysis of the treated and
untreated plants
and many different proteins that were
increased in terms of their relative
abundance
were associated with primary metabolism
and such as photosynthesis proteins
glycoglycolysis proteins proteins that
are involved in nitrogen and tca
and pathways heat shock proteins that
are
well known to assist plants in coping
with stress
as well as structural proteins and many
of these proteins that are being
expressed
in terms of central metabolism actually
facilitate um the production of
precursors that
ultimately lead to the biosynthesis
of specialized metabolites such as
southern endocytes
and even soya saplings so it's it
it is it might be possible
that these different environments that
are actually found
in the wild
might be causing differential expression
of different pathways that ultimately
lead
to a variable production of different
compounds
for example the southerlandiosides are
thought to be responsible
for the anti-cancer eternity of these
plants
whereas the flavonoids for example
actually
facilitate ross activity and
implants
and some of these uh
flavonoids that are produced are general
uh fat flavonoids chemical derivatives
at charles cones and even
southerlandioside um and so the landing
isomers which we think might be
functioning
ecologically to assist the plant cope
with its actual environment
so where to from here with southern
india
we would really be interested in
understanding
transcriptomic changes that are as a
result
of these different micro environment
micro environments the taxonomy is also
um a little bit um confusing
because some people have said that
plants that are found in the northern
cape
might actually be micro macro filler
whereas plants that are found
in the western cape are actually
a different variant
so it may be interesting to apply some
kind of
genetic analysis to to try and actually
resolve some of
some of these genetic questions which
we're now starting to
have in our heads want to bring on
a a a fairly new project that we've been
working on here
and this one is linked to a species
that's actually a pandemically
distributed species
that is known as dodeneia viscosia
viscosa
and here we set up a wild um
a wild analysis of plants in terms of
their chemistry but at the same time
we set up a common garden experiment
because we wanted
to minimize the effects of the
environment
and then we did a population genetic
structure of wild
wild plants and i will talk a little bit
about that work as well
this work was actually based on a study
that was conducted with cape bush
doctors
organization and anna martin englebrecht
who is a human physiologist that
specializes in cancer
where we uncovered anti-cancer activity
that was actually linked
to a breast cancer cell line
so different populations of the species
have got
variable anti-cancer activity
and that anti-cancer activity
is actually associated with a variety of
different aptotic
markers these plants also have
anti-angiogenesis activity which
might assist in um the non-migration of
the cancer to different
parts um in
in in patients so we would like to
commercialize this particular extract as
an adjuvant treatment
which would be utilized together with
other anti-cancer
chemotherapy and we ultimately would
like to move it
from the laboratory desk
and ultimately onto the pharmacy shelf
so i'm going to talk about some of the
work that we did in terms of the
in terms of the chemical diversity and
the genetic diversity
with regards to this particular species
so we've collected plants from different
areas
the cedarburg is a mountain area
stellenbosch
also has some mountains but it's also
quite close to the sea
and then uh the work that actually sits
in a coastal
area and all of these different
environments have got different
uh geographical uh types
and then at the same time the climates
are actually very different
so the wild population plants actually
cut
cluster into two different
types with the cedarburg type actually
clustering
um into two different clusters
and then the the whoop and the standard
wash types actually clustering
together into two different types and
what's interesting is that when we grow
this little common garden experiment
similar types of patterns are actually
observed so this led us to thinking that
perhaps the plants might not necessarily
be
having a phenotypic plastic response
but this might actually be related to
differences in population structure
so we conducted a a
population genetic
[Music]
analysis based on some microsatellites
because we thought that um these plants
might actually not necessarily control
their metabolism in a phenotypic
plastic manner but it might actually be
a genetically inherited
um difference
and so that micro satellite analysis was
actually quite interesting for us
because
it mirrored the the chemical types that
we actually saw
the cedarburg populations again were
genetically
different whereas the stellar wash
and the plants were similar in terms of
their population genetic structure
we think that the cedarburg might
actually be acting as
a genetic barrier um
and there might be greater gene flow
between
the cellular marsh population and the
plants because these plants actually are
pollinated by insects small insects that
can't travel
long distances but on the other hand
um there might be better
uh gene flow between the stellenbosch
populations and the
whoop populations rather than the
syllable populations
what was also quite interesting is that
in this common garden experiment
the ecophysiological data again
mirrored the chemical data
as well as this population genetic
data that we had generated so finally i
get to my last
example where i include
included this specifically because
several people that are listening to
this talk were involved in this
um grant proposal that um jeff was
talking about
initially and i'm going to share a
little bit of
jolene brooks's data in this particular
time
so roy boss is a very well-known tea
it's commercialized in
all different parts of the world i drank
a lot of robots when i was
at the university of minnesota um it
made it reminded me of home
and um and also i think it generally
just kept me feeling happy and healthy
this particular species is not
necessarily just
um commercialized for its
tea but all kinds of different products
are made
including wine where they use it as a
modification
system to actually mature the wine a
whole bunch of products such as
cosmetics are generated from rooibos
and in south africa it's even used
um to fortify bread
and so it really has multi uh
different uses in industry so jolene
went
out into the different parts of the
cedarburg and the northern cape
and these are actually part of the cape
floristic region
and she collected roy boss together with
the local people who know
very deep information about wild
ravers and different eco types of
rivers actually exist in the wild and
interestingly enough these different
populations of roy
somehow seem to cluster according to
sight with the cedarburg populations
actually clustering together
and the northern cape populations
clustering
in two different quadrants
so three different clusters were
actually um
obvious in terms of the wild robots that
we collected
and again many different compounds whose
chemical
identity actually remains unknown
the analyses that we did
where we used um a
plastic set of primers to
interrogate a little bit of the
historical
origins of these populations
actually led to four different
haplotypes
being being detected
and then we
then also utilized some um
nuclear markers and
interestingly enough we didn't get very
good resolution when we actually
when we did a pcoa but when our
analysis was a little bit more
supervised with a
a dpac
um different
populations could actually be be
resolved
into different um based on different
sites
so um
um hypothesized that
this genetic difference might actually
be linked
to whether these plants are reseeders or
resprouters
and because um some of the populations
are actually using a different um
strategy in terms of their reproduction
strategies
so the plants that are occurring in in
the northern
in the northern cape um actually are
mainly known to
to be resprouters whereas
the cedarburg populations are actually
using a different strategy
so we really would like to delve a
little bit
deeper into this kind of analysis and
include a much wider set of
nuclear markers collect much larger
sample sizes and actually expand this
ultimately to different species of
um spalafus genus and hopefully we'll be
able to do this
at some stage in the future so again
there's a lot of information that we
still don't understand
with regards to um aspalapus le nouris
itself and i hope
that i've been able to share some
interesting aspects with respect to my
to the work that we actually do here and
that
there's still a lot of value in using
interesting scientific tools to mine the
biodiversity of south africa
at the same time to add a new value to
indigenous knowledge that
it exists here and hopefully to grow the
buy
economy for south africa and its people
i'm happy to take questions if we have
them
i'd like to thank you for your attention
and many other people that have assisted
me in the work that i've actually been
doing
here at stellenbosch happy to take
questions
thank you knox thanks for a very nice
seminar
i have one question in the chat
christopher dunn
christopher writes is there any benefit
sharing so that some of the commercial
profits are returned to the relevant
indigenous communities yes
um so there is a lot of benefit sharing
that is actually um
[Music]
taking place and i'm going to just
sketch the scenario
and take you back to 2004
in 2004 the south african national
biodiversity
act actually added two new chapters
to it which stimul stipulate
that any indigenous
knowledge that is
exploited and ultimately commercialized
needs to have the original indigenous
knowledge holder benefit
from those fire prospecting activities
and this is actually legislated and the
department of environmental
um affairs in south africa which is a
government department
actually monitors this so for all the
work that i do i actually have to
declare to
to the government in terms of the work
that i'm proposing to do
and if any innovation is derived from it
then and that innovation is protected
through
a patent and the patent becomes licensed
and any commercialization ultimately
takes place from those activities
communities that have been the providers
of that information
needed to benefit shape and the
government actually monitors this
and the funds go into the a government
pool which then flows to the different
communities that are actually associated
as beneficiation
partners it's it's quite
difficult because some of this knowledge
is actually community knowledge that
comes from
old so it's very difficult to identify
the
the original knowledge holder
thanks knox christopher do you have any
follow-up questions about that
uh no i don't but thanks for asking jeff
that was very
very well put thank you thanks
are there other questions we're a little
over time so i
i'm going to not have too many more but
if anybody else would like to ask one
i have one question knox um are there
many genera
that have species in more than one of
these
regions of high endemism and radiation
so for example
species different species in the
succulent kuru and the
cape floristic region
um can you repeat that for me so are
there many
other genera that have men have species
in more than
one of these uh high diversity regions
like for example the
core cape floristic region and the
succulent karoo
um yes yeah absolutely so
um yeah i mean i you know it's it's
really quite
um so quite interesting that
you know some of you some of these
plants are not necessarily just located
in the in these areas
but they've actually kind of um
radiated like throughout the whole
entire
country for example so they actually
found
you know in many other different areas
apart from these
i would say hot spots it's just that
they may be concentrated
in some of these hot spots um
in terms of their
their numbers i don't know
if that kind of answers you yeah it does
i mean i'm interested in thinking about
if there are cases like that whether
there are
uh patterns in the chemistry that would
be typical
that you'd see repeated over and over
again as you go from a
genera that have species in the
different regions so the generalizations
about
the chemistry that that would be there
as well sort of a follow-up to that
so yeah okay ariel johnson ariel you've
got a
question
yeah um thanks for the awesome seminar
um i'm really
curious uh if the meson brain
in the scalidium um if it's like
concentrated in any of the cells like um
like beyond the organs like if if you
happen to know because
uh sort of like the bladder cells or
like other idioblasts or
um i'm just curious if that
might be the case i guess the fact that
in the culture
um it's still able to produce the
compounds might indicate that it's not
um but i was curious if you're
investigating like the cellular
localization of these compounds
we at this stage haven't actually done
any of that kind of
um analysis um
where we actually sort of take a
you know a piece and then kind of
strip it away and actually look at at
that analysis
we haven't even done any um analysis
just to even understand
um some of the primary steps because
this
mesmery is actually synthesized from
tyrosine so we might be able to use
some of the primary steps um
that are actually common to betalyne
synthesis to try and maybe see
where it might be produced but
at this particular stage we haven't
actually done any of that kind of work
i i'm thinking in my mind it might be
nice to
feed radio labels and then kind of track
them and see what
what's going on but that could be a fun
experiment
but we haven't done it yet well thank
you
all right well i think we'll we're
losing our audience because i think
we're people who have to go to meetings
and things like that chelsea spec root
and thank you for a wonderful seminar
but she had to leave and so
i want to thank you again knox it was a
lot of fun and
uh good luck and i hope we'll be in
touch about the the roibos
projects as well yes thank you very much
and i look forward to some more
interactions
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu